hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 11 of
book four of his discourses Epictetus is
going to talk about cleaning the bottom
bodily cleanliness or purifying it if
you like now why would he be focused on
that sort of thing you know if you want
to play a little bit of what they call
devil's advocate and say aren't you
stoics primarily concerned with the soul
and don't you think that the body
doesn't really matter you know after all
it's one of those externals not where
you're supposed to find your good or a
place you're good so what's going on
here epictetus could of course respond
well externals do matter and our use of
them is important and we live in the
world in which our relations with other
people are in fact mediated by being in
modeling existence with them so all of
that is is going to be taken into
consideration you can also see something
else going on that will become apparent
towards the end of this discussion on
epictetus I get put here takes cleaning
the body as a distinctively human trait
perhaps not something that we would
necessarily agree with now but he does
see it as something at least in his
time where you know animals would clean
themselves and then people would say AHA
that's like a person so he thinks that
that cleanliness is something
distinctive to human beings that other
animals can share in in a sort of in a
metaphorical way or partial way but but
is really something distinctively human
in part because it's really something
connected with their relationship with
the divine and as he says here we go we
consider cleanliness to be a special
characters to command driving in the
first instance from the gods for since
the gods are by nature pure and
undefiled insofar as men have approached
them by virtue of reason just so far
that are they attached to purity and
cleanliness and then it says but it is
impossible for the nature of man to be
altogether pure seeing it's how it's
composed of such material as it is the
reason that they received from the gods
endeavors to render this material clean
as far as possible so if you think about
our body our body is in Kentucky you
know continual flux you can work at one
part of it and that can be a good shape
and then it seems like other things are
always going wrong sore like a old car
or a house that's continually needing a
bit of repair you know the older you get
the more you realize that the body is
indeed like that but epictetus thinks
that we want to pay attention to the way
in which our body exists and how we
treat it so he will say that the most
primary kind of cleanliness is the
Columbus of the soul and what is it for
something to be clean it means for it to
be in good condition for performing its
function so what are the functions of
the soul he goes on he says exercise of
choice refusal desire aversion
preparation purpose and I said all these
things that we associate with the mine
what then would make the soul dirty or
unclean what would get in there and gum
up the works what would
through things up in that way the way
that dirt and grime do for machinery
well it would be what we call they add
judgments or dogma in the Greek right
opinions is another way of translating
viewpoints upon things when we have bad
judgments then that creates an impurity
within our minds and sometimes it can
get so dirty that we don't even realize
it and this can be reflected also in a
kind of bodily uncleanliness when
somebody gets so distraught that they
just stop paying attention to their
appearance and the basic personal
hygiene epictetus you know talks about
that sort of case he even talks about
people who think of themselves as
unworthy of cleaning themselves of
course his advice that is do you think
everybody else is worthy of you know
taking in your odor at the same time
maybe you should think about them so
let's go on he says we want to maintain
some basic standards of cleanliness and
actually I don't want to bring on
something that I didn't put on the board
just as a sort of aside he says is
anyone demanding that you beautify
yourself he says heaven forbid except
you beautify the averages our true
nature the reason its judgments its
activities but your body you only have
to go so far as to keep it cleanly only
so far as to avoid giving offense you
don't need to you know go to the gym to
get ripped you don't need to wear a lot
of makeup you don't need to buy the
latest fashion you don't need to use
very fancy exfoliants or creams or
whatever it is that people use I don't
know that much about that but they were
in existence in Roman times too if
people could spend a lot of money on
that you don't need to buy expensive
perfumes or colognes or aftershaves or
what have you all you need to do is make
tain certain basic stance but why should
you do that well one thing that he
points out is look you've got the
resources to do that and he's got some
very funny examples here that it uses he
says it's impossible that there should
be no discharge of mucus from the nose
since man's body has been composed as it
is you've got sinuses sinuses drip right
so what are you going to do with it are
you going to you know he's talking about
that we have different names for this
when I was a kid we'd call it snarfing
it up right where people just sort of
inhale the mucus back into their system
Sky Country it's a good way to get sick
right it's also not very attractive to
do that you should blow your nose right
and that big penis is saying quite
frankly he says uh here we go if a man
stuffs back these discharge the me
because he's not acting as a human being
should why because Nature Made hands he
said you can blow your nose likewise if
you don't like taking a hot bath he says
a little bit later take a cold bath but
take a bath because that's a possibility
for you he gives a lot of other examples
you know if you don't want your teeth to
be dirty well you can brush them they
didn't have I think brushes at that time
but they would clean them with rags or
other sorts of things he goes on and he
says ah it's impossible that something
dirty and needing to be cleaned off
should not be left on the person from
our sweat the pressure of our clothes so
for that reason we've got other things
right we've got water oil hands a towel
astragal nighter and on occasion every
other candidate equipment to cleanse the
body what he's talking about there are
all the basic tools that were used in
the greek and roman baths to clean the
body so you know in our own time we
might say things like well if you want
to be clinging it's not tough to do just
find yourself some soap and maybe some
shampoo and
toothbrush and some toothpaste and get
started there and that's then you can go
charters more and more complex but those
are the basics that will probably put
you in good stead he also thinks that we
should keep the body in good condition
in part because it's something that we
have been given so he has this metaphor
of being given a horse he says if nature
committed to your own to your care horse
would you have utterly neglected it and
now I would like you to think that your
body has been entrusted to you like a
horse wash it rub it down make it so
that nobody will turn his back on you or
move aside if we are given this body we
should take care of it there are certain
minimal standards of care we don't have
again we don't have to go hog wild you
know this is probably extend to exercise
but we don't need to be in the gym three
hours a day and we don't need to be
trying to meet some sort of in a weird
culturally conditioned standard of
beauty that is almost difficult almost
impossible to to attain you get the idea
there there are certain things that we
ought to be doing to take care of our
bodies and maintaining some basic
cleanliness as part of that you know by
the way epictetus would probably say
since you know research has shown us
that that taking a shower and every
single day might not be the best idea
because it strips off oils from the skin
washing your hair every day might not be
the best idea so I'm gonna wash it twice
a week or take a shower every other day
or do all these words of things but with
the purpose of maintaining the body
there's another very important function
to this as well which is that we don't
offend other people by our lack of
hygiene we are social animals it is
important epictetus things not just on
an etiquette not just out of the kind of
fastidiousness but in an ethical sense
not to give other people the fence when
we don't have to so again as an example
where he says
here we go you're doing something of the
sort even here and do not realize it you
think you're worthy of the smell though
there's people who are you know don't
really care that they stink right very
well be worthy of it that's fine for you
do you think though that those who sit
by your side those who recline beside
you those who kiss you are worthy of it
to go away into a wilderness somewhere
or other place worthy of you live alone
smelling of yourself it's his advice
because you're rendering yourself not
really fit to take part in human society
the last thing that I want to bring up
that he talks about here that's very
interesting he he talks about bodily
cleanliness providing a starting point
for something greater so it's not a you
know it ended itself he says there we go
I should have ran through you have the
young man who is experiencing the first
stirrings towards philosophy so new
students right come to me with his hair
carefully dressed than with it in a
state of desperate neglect and dirty why
does m'bek you just care about how
people look when they show up to class
this is a question we get asked about
you know professors and students today
where sometimes students will come in
their pajamas or in all sorts of you
know strange outfits that probably
shouldn't be worn in a classroom or not
haven't showered for several days or
terrible cases sometimes weeks he says
in the first case shows that there
exists in the young man a sort of
imaging of beauty and aiming and
comeliness and where he fancies it to be
that's the body there he devotes his
efforts with that as a starting point
all that is necessary has shown the way
and say young man you're seeing the
beautiful and you do well know them that
it arises in that part of you where you
have your reason in the beauty of the
mind in the cleanliness of the mind so
we see coming back full circle to this
main point that the primary cleanliness
is of the soul we focus on our bond
these because we're given those and they
are to a certain extent a reflection of
our souls or our minds and if you think
that it's important to clean and
beautify the body then we should think
even more so of our minds or our souls